so I tell people the freedom that MSR
has which is you can come here and be
whatever you want if you want to be a
developer just like building a product
yes you can be that if you want to be an
entrepreneur literally running startup
like thinking about the business value
of things you can be that and if you
want to be an academic person absolutely
you can be that as well here's a place
that you could come to and choose what
you want to be and you can keep
switching what you are as your progress
here carrier here and isn't that amazing
you're listening to the Microsoft
Research podcast a show that brings you
closer to the cutting edge of technology
research and the scientists behind it
I'm your host Gretchen using
[Music]
dr. Lennon Ravindranath Sybil Ingham is
a researcher by trade but by nature he's
an entrepreneur and a hacker with a
heart of gold it's this combination of
skill and passion that informs his work
at Microsoft Research driving him to
discover and build tools that will make
life both easier for developers and
better for end-users today dr. civil
Ingham tells us why he is so passionate
about what he does explains how
internships can literally change your
life and shares the story of how a
hackathon idea turned into a
prize-winning project and then became
the backbone of a powerhouse tool for
gamers and their fans that and much more
on this episode of the Microsoft
Research podcast
[Music]
Lenin ravindran of Seville Ingham
welcome to the podcast
thanks thanks for inviting me you're a
researcher in systems and networking at
MSR what gets you up in the morning what
are the big questions you're trying to
answer and the big problems you're
trying to solve I'm a researcher in the
systems and networking here and my
research focus actually spans across the
stack if you think about any systems
even from my mobile to cloud
applications I think a lot about the
developers who develop these
applications you know how do you make
their lives really easy what is kind of
the hard challenges that they face so if
you look at a developer lifecycle you
have to build the application they have
to test the application they have to
deploy it and your job is not done yet
you have to monitor it and iterate on it
so how do you make each stage of the
pipeline really easy for developers very
specific challenges that you have to
tackle one thing I noticed when we
talked before is that you're incredibly
passionate about the work you do what
makes you so passionate about the
systems in networking research and why
is it important to you I think at heart
I'm like a hacker so that's how I was
brought up so I was like a programmer
and a developer at heart so a lot of the
problems I try to solve in my research
I'm very close to my heart the kind of
challenges that I face when I'm trying
to build a big system I'm trying to
solve a consumer problem I'm a developer
I want to spend like three months
building this right the kind of
challenges I face I bring that back into
my research so the next developer who
comes in and who wants to build similar
things I want to make their life really
really easy so I think that's where the
passion comes from because the problems
are so close to the heart so you
mentioned your focus is on two main
areas of research interest and your
primary interest is developer
productivity tools let's talk about your
work for developers tell us how and why
you got interested in that line of
research and what you want to accomplish
absolutely I think last 10 years even
through my grad school every one of my
project kind of focused on you know a
developer centric perspective of things
how do you make it easy for developers
to do a certain task in grad school I
focus a lot on you know mobile develop
that was a time Android was coming up
iPhone was coming up mobile developers
were coming up there were lots of new
challenges we could actually go and
solve idea after I came to Microsoft I
shifted my focus towards the cloud
how do people build cloud scale
applications right so what are the
challenges in building those
applications today if you want to build
a cloud application it has many
different components okay even a very
simple application you want to build a
notetaking application where you store
something in the database and show it to
people later you have to build a
front-end you have to build some sort of
storage and if you want to authenticate
the users you contact some
authentication provider so lots of
components off the bat that you have to
start even for a very simple application
of course cloud application are
typically built in a way that they are
pretty highly concurrent so building
cloud scale application is challenging
and worse the place where these
applications run which is your data
centers are kind of fault prone your
network could be slower your VMs could
reboot the external provider that you're
contacting is not available so you have
to account for them three it's very hard
for developers to be very frank so I can
have go after those problems mmm I take
like a specific instance of a problem I
built an application I'm gonna put it in
the cloud I'm not sure where it's going
to break right so how do you enable them
give them the inside during their
testing process that these bad things
can happen sure so that you can address
it upfront before putting it out because
after you put it out you have like not
many chances okay if a person comes to
your application and it's not available
for the next two hours you're going to
drive them away so it will be very
careful in noticing these bugs before
putting in an introduction you talk
about the four stages of the development
lifecycle write test deploy monitor talk
in general about the spectrum of
research if you can that's going on to
make it easier for developers to tackle
that at various stages of the cycle
particularly as it relates to the cloud
now I'm pretty sure you know if you ask
different people there are different
number of stages so from my perspective
based on a lot of developers I've talked
to and me being a developer I
categorize them at a high level to four
stages sure you have an idea on you
build the application that's kind of the
first stage once you build it you do
some form of testing to make sure that
you don't break it and of course the
third stages it's running in your
desktop so I call that kind of the
deployment stage and we talked about the
challenges there and finally of course
you've deployed your application as I
said your job is not done you have to
monitor it how it's doing right with
respect to your customers in terms of
performance is it handling failures and
all of that so those are kind of the
four stages and I'll maybe do it a
little bit deeper into each of these
stages would you yeah okay absolutely
and talk about the high level problems
so in the building part of the stage of
course I think the trend where it is
going right now is you want to make it
extremely easy for developers to build
their applications once they come up
with an idea I want to put three four
libraries together I want to mix and
match in a certain way and have my
application ready in a couple of days
right so that's the trend with which
even Microsoft is going lots of other
companies are going right so you provide
these really high level libraries that
can tackle everything for you so that
all that you need to come up with is an
idea
yeah and in that area I've worked quite
a bit of course there how the research
area looks like is you take a particular
domain where you know this is a very
storage centric application where the
performance of storage should be you
know really really fast and reliable and
all of that so how do you abstract that
to the developer how do you provide
tools to the developer so that they
don't have to worry about these things
even if it's extremely storage centric
they don't have to worry about
performance reliability and cost this of
course a big issue today and you wanted
to apply something in the cloud right so
there are specific domains that we have
taken we talked about video analytics
tools at some point if you want to build
application that does video analysis if
you take the developer centric
perspective how do i mix and match a few
dn ends from here and there and put them
together and run them efficiently and
there I have an application for a dome
right so that's kind of the build part
of the stage but you want to kind of
build tools that abstracts to the
highest level possible and then of
course comes the test
which is absolutely my favorite part of
the stage because a lot of developers
just ignore it I talked to so many
developers and testing is the last thing
that they wanted why do you think that
is it's kind of a very non gratifying
process I guess the creativity process
is what is gratifying you thought about
something and you created something is
very gratifying right testing is sort of
something that you have to do so that
you retain your customers and that makes
it you know a very low hanging fruit for
doing research you know the developer
mentality that they don't want to spend
a lot of effort in testing systems so
how do you make things as automatic as
possible you take an application you
press three buttons seven hours later it
says you have all these kinds of books
that is the vision with which I tackle
the testing research area and we'll talk
about some specific projects in there
which is one of my favorite and recent
projects which gave me like widely
deployed in Microsoft so that's kind of
a testing stage and of course there is
this big deploying stage when it comes
to actually cloud scale applications not
necessarily actually a big stage and
mobile application and on other domains
so the deployment stage is very crucial
in cloud scale applications because you
have a lot of choice okay so when I
actually go to Azure it gives me you
know 300 different VMs that I can deploy
if I make a mistake I pay probably 10x
more cost then I should have paid right
so that's a really hard process for
developers they either under spend and
actually hit some limits in terms of
scalability or people over production
today right so how do you make them
optimally you know both spend their
resources and cost is a very crucial
problem which I've looked at in the past
yeah and finally monitoring the
application right it's monitoring is not
very different from testing by the way
the big problem there is you have to
kind of scalability monitor an
application and when you find a bug what
kind of feedback do you give the
developer so that they can fix it very
quickly if I just Montand say yeah this
customer came in on the request failed
it's not enough so the rich area that is
you know root causing the problems I'm
monitoring an optic
and it failed but give a feedback to
developer that will give him very
actionable fixes and that's something I
focused on as well both in the grad
school and at Microsoft Research all
right so let's drill in on your favorite
part of the cycle right now which is
testing talk about the specific projects
you have going on there I know this
topic is near and dear to the developers
heart absolutely especially again I'll
just focus on the cloud application
testing part of it so I want to kind of
reiterate the problems which is you know
I want to simply say modern cloud
applications are just complex as I said
they are built in a very distributed way
the runtime the way information flows is
very a synchronous because you want to
handle a lot of requests at the same
time so you have to be careful how you
process the information
if you don't process them in a
consistent way it kind of leads to these
really hard to find bugs the class of
bugs that we call concurrency bugs ok
these are really hard to find and in
fact when we go through and talk to some
teams and who have faced these problems
you know the way they solve these
problems they think ok they hit a
concurrency bug but the problem is they
take ours and I was finding all the
combinations of code that could have
actually occurred the permutation all
the permutations and combinations that
could have come to hit that concurrency
bug so that's really hard for developers
yeah so my focus has been how do you go
after these hot to find bugs and find
them before they have deploy to
production because after you hit it it's
very hard to find right and if you hit
it these are kind of there are bugs that
bring your system down so I also want to
point out another hot to find bug which
is when you deploy to the cloud as I
said this is a very fault prone
environment then you are actually
testing your program in your computer
and if this is a problem it's a single
mission you test all of it everything
works you move to the cloud suddenly a
service is not available that's it your
application is not working anymore for
the customers right so that's another
hard to find bug that you want to
predict before it happens so these are
kind of sometimes the combination of
both ok so we actually built a system
that can find these hard to find bugs
before
stammers deploy to production and before
going into the system I also want to
talk about how people do that today you
tell a team yeah your system is highly
concurrent you can hit concurrency bugs
how do you find it today there are two
extremes on one extreme that people
don't put any extra effort is I will put
my system in a staging deployment run a
lot of stress tests for one week and I'm
gonna pray and hope that I will get a
bug there right some teams also kind of
like reroute their part of users traffic
to the staging deployment so that
they'll find something the coverage is
of course very low but in terms of
developer effort nothing right I'm just
running it for a week and checking what
is going on so that's one extreme on the
other extreme actually there are very
sophisticated tools like TL a-plus which
also actually came out of Microsoft
Research where you model your system you
express it in a different language and
the language can reason about these two
categories of bus so both these
concurrency bugs and fault tolerance
books the problem there is this is a
additional it's like significantly
additional effort for the developer
right which is you have to separately
maintain this modeling language as you
update your code you have to update the
model so there are two extremes now
let's see where our project kind of fits
so this specific instance of the project
actually achieved the best of both
worlds which is we make it similarly
zero effort for the developer just run
your existing test stress test put it in
a staging deployment on all of it but we
take these sophisticated algorithms that
the systematic testing tools like TL A+
have and apply it on that environment
okay so it's kind of the best of both
worlds so all we say is don't change
your behavior all that you are doing is
some form of testing do it but do it
with our tool
yeah and suddenly our tool kind of
amplifies your tests to explore all
these paths to find what could happen in
production so is this still in research
or is this actually it's getting widely
deployed in Microsoft and we have
achieved quite a bit of success in
actually finding I won't say how many
bugs but like via foreign
tons of bugs I mean like critical bugs
that could
happened in production
there's some amazing research projects
going on in live video stream analysis
tell us about your research in this area
and what technical challenges are you
addressing what methods are you using to
solve them and what results are you
seeing I have like a simple story why I
got into it right I've been a very
developer focused person why did I get
into kind of live video stream analysis
right two reasons I think the last 15
years analyzing video has fascinated me
you know since the time we got a def jam
at home and I actually figured out that
you can program that webcam to read
pixels out of all the images that are
coming in I mean building like all sorts
of small applications as like side
projects one of it is you know we got a
bird feeder at home and then I set up
basically a camera and write a program
to say that's a squirrel ever come to
the bird feeder right so this has been
kind of a very fascinating thing for me
since I was very young so that's one
reason I have always continued keeping
the live video analysis as one of my
side projects the number two thing is of
course the last two three years
computer vision has become mainstream
and in fact our research community and
our team started embracing it because VR
systems people and of course these are
kind of large-scale systems that consume
a lot of resources so we started taking
that route but I got into it again
because of the developer perspective
that I had which is you know how do I
make it extremely easy for developers to
build cloud scale computer vision
applications how do you mix and match
these things in a certain way so that
you can adapt it to your domain so
that's how I got into it again from a
very developer centric point of view but
it has taken its own form and it's like
we are running with it so let's talk
about one of the best applications of
that technology hype zone you know this
is a big thing yeah most of our
listeners if they're gamers will know
all about it already but what's cool
about it what's different about it again
a little bit of a story how we created
the hype zone ah I was going into this
developer centric view of you know how
do you make it extremely easy for
developers to build computer vision
application and we actually took a
instance of it
we participated in the Microsoft
one-week hackathon they were like 18,000
participants and like 4,000 projects so
we had a instance offered which tackled
a kind of a specific application and we
actually won the grand prize the in fact
we push this back without yeah so that
is where actually a lot of focus on live
video stream analysis for consumer
started so something like hype zone is a
gaming area which is a lot of consumers
so once we won the hackathon of course
it was lots of teams and Microsoft who
came back to us and said you know Bob
you have a cool technology we should
apply to what we have and see if we can
create some really unique experiences so
hype zone is actually a set of channels
on mixer for people who don't know what
mixer is mixer is sorry I'm still on
where people actually stream their
gameplay to the entire world so that's
what mixer is what is hype zone hives on
is actually set of channels in mixer
that continuously shows you down to the
wire interesting games that are going on
in mixer like in all the thousands of
streams that are in mixer what's the
most interesting game that is going on
right now so let's take an example game
for tonight which is kind of a cultural
phenomenon right now everybody knows
that either you are playing it or your
kid is playing it so you take a game
like fortnight a single game takes like
30 to 45 minutes for people to finish
it's typically kind of the endgame that
is like super interesting so how do you
analyze all live video streams that are
coming into mixer finding who's playing
that really intense endgame and showcase
it in a very dedicated channel this is
like the NFL red zone of 49 right and
you keep showing it and this is being
like hugely successful right people see
like interesting content all the time
it's not just about the viewers by the
way the streamers gets so excited
getting highlighted on the hype zone
because if you look at like a platform
like mixer you have certain celebrities
that people follow and typically these
pop and coming streamers are not very
visible what the hype zone did was if
you're a good gamer you'll get featured
too you know thousands of people who
will watch you so streamers get super
excited when they get featured on the
hive zone so
this worked out as a win-win for us
consumers were so happy because it was
interesting content streamers are so
happy because you know they get featured
on it so let's drill in on the
technology behind it a little bit
because you talked about the hackathon
and and what goes on there is like you
say for people who love to sell